in today's money watch we're talking
about the cost of college a huge issue
for many families Nationwide as they
struggle with high inflation May 1st is
known as National College decision day
and the clock is ticking for high school
seniors to decide where they will go the
cost of tuition has skyrocketed jumping
more than 35 percent in the past decade
or so right now the average total cost
of going to an in-state public College
which includes tuition room and board
and books is about twenty six thousand
dollars a year it's about forty four
thousand dollars a year for out-of-state
students and about fifty four thousand
dollars a year for private non-profit
colleges CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here good morning she's
here to break it all down like boxes on
recycling day so let's jump right into
it financial aid packages they can be
very very confusing it is so difficult
because there's not a uniform way that
every college in the United States has
to report to you and your family what
these numbers mean so imagine you could
to be pretty confused Grant scholarship
loan what's what yeah so here's the
thing what's free what's what's free and
a lot of times the words sound different
in each letter so you really have to go
back to the school and say okay hold on
what's free money what's the loan and if
this is a loan what are the terms of the
loan what is this going to cost me by
the way if you do get somebody on the
phone at that school you might say how
can we sweeten the financial aid offer
it actually does work mostly if your kid
calls him or herself because if the
parent calls it doesn't work as well so
the really hard thing with college is
it's an investment right you're paying x
amount and you hope to get x amount back
and the money you'll make as an employee
somewhere how does a high school senior
who has say admission to an expensive
higher ranked academic institution weigh
that versus admission to like a a public
College that's lower cost maybe doesn't
have the name recognition how do they I
mean it doesn't cost us such a gift I
think the big problem with the rankings
is that many of the big rankings that
we've all talked about for years and
years they're kind of being debunked
because these are self-reported metrics
right the school says hey Tony went to
school here here's how much money he
makes so there's actually a really
interesting new tool out from the New
York Times that allows you to customize
the variables that matter to you and I
really think this is important because
what's important to me might be
different than for Gail or Nate or you
and so what I think people need to
really consider is that the value of a
college degree is immense people do make
more over their lifetimes with a college
degree than with a high school degree
but if you go into so much debt to get
that degree it may not work out to be
the same return on that investment but I
like Tony's question so you're saying if
you have a choice between a hiring
school that's more expensive maybe you
should rethink that because absolutely
because if you are putting pressure on
you as a student coming out or your
family that has a whole different
different set of ramifications so what's
the right amount to borrow for college
then you know there's been a rule of
thumb I've talked about it on the show
in the past that I really like for a
student him or herself I think it's
great to try to say I will make my total
borrowing less than my projected first
year salary my projected first year
salary so you know what let's say I'm
going to be a docent at a uh Art Gallery
numbers yeah that might be thirty
thousand dollars okay let's say I'm
going to be a software engineer that
might be eighty thousand dollars but if
you're the parent the other thing to
consider is if you're looking at all of
your own borrowing as a family you might
say hey let's keep our borrowing for all
of our children less than one annual
years of salary and I think this is
really good it's a good way to stay out
of trouble so Tony mentioned this
investment right you invest in a college
hoping to get that in return so you can
start your life as an adult and make
money
um there there was a recent poll um in
the Wall Street Journal more than half
of Americans believe believe that a
four-year degree is a Bad Bet so I ask
in your opinion this is why we have you
here is going to to college and getting
that degree
a good thing nowadays first of all we've
just come off of that survey after a
very hot job market so that's number one
but what we do know is based on the
numbers a high school degree lifetime
earnings you will earn less than with a
college degree and actually every single
degree that you get the numbers go up
dramatically so if I say a high school
degree versus an associate degree versus
a college degree Master's PhD
professional the numbers go up
exponentially there's a big but again if
you borrow too much for a degree that
does not pay an adequate salary to
service that debt you're in trouble and
can I point out the level of interest
rates has really changed these equations
remember when many people were getting
their student loans they were getting
three four percent loans from the
federal government the range of federal
government loans right now is for
undergraduates you're five percent if
you're getting a parent a plus loan it's
almost more than seven and a half
percent this can weigh on your future
for quite some time remember all the
things that you can't do while you are
actually shouldering that debt burden no
retirement no emergency Reserve no debt
paydown calculation college level math
you might say
yeah thank you very much you're always
the best I had the national teacher of
the year winner will join us to talk
about how we can ensure the next
generation gets the best education
possible stay with us
today's money watch is sponsored by
Edward Jones Life Is For Living let's
partner for all of it